[__] people trying to [__] with me
but i love my wife she's a we got a baby
the baby's great
she's happy and that's all that [__]
matters to me it's tough being a dad
when you're a savage you know
i have a beautiful little girl i'm a
[__] savage she's gonna find that
eventually
and she sits next to me like a [__]
bodyguard like she won't leave me to
[__] alone i mean it's amazing she pulls
me by this thing to come
and i gotta sit there and why and i love
her to death but i don't know what to do
with us i'm a [__] savage you know
when you're a savage you know all the
real fears of the world you're decent
people you know what i'm saying you
you never muck the gas station attendant
you never pimped out sticky [__]
charlie
you have no worries your credit's clear
up in heaven i got problems i'm a sinner
you understand me
i am i'm [__] up man and then i gotta
lie to her when she gets old daddy you
smoke pot never
i don't even know what the [__] you're
talking about
stop being a dad man especially when you
have a beautiful little girl i don't
know how to act the next couple of years
i just
all i could do is give well i go to the
park where i want to smack little boys
already
smack them like they take the frisbee
from i want to kick that [__]
like just go over
and give like one of these kicks to the
back of the [__] head you little [__]
get out of here
because i don't want you know the big
thing couple months ago a year ago was
the kids getting bullied i don't want my
daughter to go through
i never got bullied i never heard of
such things
i never heard of such things i got
bullied one time
some kid [__] took my ball and kicked
it he was like 17 i was like 14.
he kicked it and i jumped him and he
beat me up he bit slapped me but the cop
across the street saw it
and he called my house to see how i was
and my mom answered the phone
and when i came home i ripped my pants
my mom goes how'd you get that rip in
your pants i was playing basketball she
goes nothing
else happened today i go nuts she was
okay i [__] went upstairs did
homework the next day came home from
school my mom had a warm-up suit on
[__]
with the rocky theme in the background
i'm like you're exercising that's great
she goes no come on we're walking over
to the [__] park that [__]
walked me over to the park and on the
way over there she's like i heard some
guy smack you and you didn't smack him
back we're gonna go take care of that
[__] today
i'm like no mommy no we're spanish they
hate us already you know what i'm saying
she's like no we're gonna go [__]
take care of this [__] right [__] now
and then we walked around there was like
20 kids there go he's not there she goes
we'll pick one
pick one we're gonna go straight one of
them out [__] it just for maybe the
future
and we walked up there she went up to
the kid with her broken english she said
excuse me because after a while i tell
the truth it was him
and my mom went up to the cake excuse me
you hit my song yesterday pow pow
today one more time pow pow and i was
like what
and she looked at me in spanish and she
goes listen you're gonna punch him in
the [__] face with everything you got
well i'm gonna knock him out and then
i'm gonna knock you the [__] out
i said [__] it he goes for nothing i
took his swing and i hit him
but then he beat me up we got the same
result as the day before
my mom picked me up we shook hands on
the walk on my mom taught me nothing
wrong
nothing you could nothing happen you got
beat up but at least you fought
that guy will never talk [__] about you
next time he hits you you get a chair
and you bust it over his head
and every time he calms his head he'll
hit that scar they'll think of you
that's how you deal with [__] bullies
that's how i grew up with bullies
you [__] are making
documentaries and
when i was a little kid my mom would
take me to the park she had hand signals
like knockout you know
uppercut like knockout a kick to the
balls my mom didn't [__] around
i don't know what goes on now we live in
the society where we take care too much
i can't i have to raise my daughter to
be a [__] savage because
i'm raising my daughter to break [__]
elbows you know
gotta raise him to do jiu jitsu that's
that's the zone right there anybody gets
in that zone [__] elbows bop
it's over be a bunch of [__] freaks
walking around with busted elbows and
[__]
so that's how i look at you want to make
your daughter the best she could be
stabbing [__] you know
i don't want my daughter coming home my
boyfriend hit me what you should have
killed that [__]
she's gonna slice this [__] neck off
you're gonna stay hit by some [__]
man get the [__] out of my face
you cook that [__] in me and you
stab him when he's sleeping
my mom did that too she didn't stab my
stepfather she hit him in the head with
a saint the catholic saying she had a
big one she just blasted him
when he was sleeping he ran out of the
house i'll never come back here again
he didn't say he said that in spanish
[Laughter]